this is the view from overhead the
picturesque german town of
shuld flooded after record rains
much of the wine producing region now
destroyed
after the rhine river burst its banks
bringing down dozens of homes another 25
houses
are at the risk of collapse
there is mud everywhere in the houses
the bridge there collapsed
water overflowed further down even
houses have floated away so it's an
emergency like world war
ii the flood has forced many to flee to
their rooftops
waiting to be rescued others wading
through waters
doing what they can to slow the floods
the government has declared a state of
emergency and deployed the army
people in nearby towns have been told to
leave the area
but rescue operations are being hampered
villages are cut off by flood water and
landslides
making them difficult to reach phone and
internet connections are also down
our storm what you see here now is worse
than after a bombing raid and this is
guaranteed to take 10 years
the people are all broke the businesses
have been hurt so it's just horrible now
the once in a generation floods are not
limited to germany
neighboring belgium and the netherlands
have also been hit hard
and with the slow-moving storm retaining
its power
forecasters say there could be more
damage and disruption to come
join wolf al jazeera
well as julian mentioned the netherlands
has also been affected let's speak to
steph vassen now she joins us from
valkenburg
near the border with germany and a step
the water line over your shoulder looks
very high indeed
what's happening there
yes exactly people are really taken by
surprise here also in this side of the
border the whole border region basically
between
the netherlands germany and belgium is
now flooded rescue workers are going
from door to door
right behind me knocking on the doors
because they're
trying to save people who have been
stuck there since uh yesterday
because that was when the water suddenly
got really high
after three days of continuous downpours
it's unprecedented flooding here
in this part of the netherlands they
never seen a thing like this before
rivers are overflooded i'm here in
valkenburg which is a tourist
center lots of tourists were here but
hundreds of people have now been
evacuated
to safer places also elderly homes have
been evacuated a bridge has collapsed
and the damage of course is uh immense
and the the
authorities here are really asking for
help the military has actually moved in
as well
to try to evacuate as many people as
possible
nobody knows until when this flooding is
happening the currents
maybe you can see it are very strong
it's really the river
has taken over this part of the city
okay step faster live for us in
valkenburg thank you very much
indeed